It's great to welcome to the program today.
Nicholas Carr, who's the author of several
books on technology and culture, including
the Pulitzer Prize finalist, The Shallows
What the Internet is Doing to Our Brains.
So great to have you on.
I really appreciate your time.
Thanks very much, David.
My pleasure.
So to start with, I think there's probably
a lot of people in my audience who generally
have the sense that maybe over the last many
years it's become a little more difficult
to do, sort of deeper, deeper learning, focusing
on one task for an extended period of time.
There's some vague notion that maybe there's
something about social media in 140 character
posts that may be sort of retraining our brain
to some extent.
But how do you generally characterize the
way that the modern Internet and technology
have changed the way that we mostly do our
thinking?
I think human beings have trouble concentrating,
have trouble screening out distractions.
In general, we're very distractable and you
really do have to practice that and train
yourself to concentrate and focus.
And I think what the Internet does in general,
and certainly social media in particular,
is it doesn't give us either the opportunity
or the encouragement to train ourselves and
and practice skills of attentiveness because
it just floods us with with information, information
that's interesting to us and grabs our attention,
but in little chunks.
And so my argument is that essentially what
we pay to get this abundance of fast flowing
information is our ability to concentrate.
We can't tap into those deeper, more attentive
ways of thinking.
Is there something that's adaptive.
From an evolutionary standpoint about being
easily distracted in the sense of you're building
a fire, but there's a threat off in the distance
and so your mind goes to that shiny object,
they're moving object or something along those
lines?
I think that's exactly it.
You know, you can you can understand how in
the distant past.
In order to stay alive, in order to survive,
you need to know everything that was going
on around you, particularly anything new which
might be a threat or might be an opportunity
to eat or whatever.
So, ah, the way our brains work is that we're
rewarded with dopamine and other ways, little
pleasure producing chemicals to gather information.
And I think it's exactly that, that this is
an evolutionary instinct that unfortunately
we bring over into this new digital environment
where there's no end to new bits of information
to grab and briefly hold our attention.
One thing I've read and heard from some folks
is the idea that there was a time in human
history not that long ago, really, where there
would be a big debate over a fact because
we did not have facts so readily accessible
on our phones.
And that I mean, this is a very sort of utopian
outlook now that the facts don't need to be
argued about.
We just find them.
We can devote more time.
Thanks to the Internet and the ready availability
of facts to thinking about the implications
of those facts or the future of humanity,
how we should interpret that information or
whatever the case may be, it feels intuitively
like that's not what's going on.
But what do you think about that idea anyway?
I think, you know, I think it does go on sometimes,
really.
Okay.
There are there are good uses of the Internet
and not so good.
But there are a couple of problems with that
that we've learned.
One is that actually having a super abundance
of information available means anybody can
find support for any kind of belief, even
though even if it's totally wrong.
So the idea that we'd all share this base
of facts turns out not to be right.
Human nature gets in the way.
And then the other problem with that is I
think when you're distracted all the time,
when you're constantly taking in information,
you don't have time in your own mind to make
connections and associations between all the
different pieces of information around you.
And it's those associations and connections
that are required to give you the bigger context
to fit new information into.
And that broadens your thinking.
Deepens your thinking.
So.
So, yeah, we can Google all sorts of stuff
on our phones or on our computers, but we're
losing our ability to fit new information
into a bigger context.
And as a result, we're just kind of turning
into.
I would argue, information gatherers that
don't necessarily have an ability to engage
in a deeper conversation with one another
or in a deeper train of thought within ourselves.
There's some interesting articles I'm reminded
of about this idea of the political hobbyist,
which seems very much related to what you're
talking about, which is given so much free
access to information about what's taking
place in the world politically.
Comments from elected officials.
A lot of data, so to speak.
There's arguably a less effective political
activist that comes out of it because they
are just consuming information, sort of as
you're pointing out, and not actually taking
that information and doing something with
it to politic, political differences aside,
to try to influence sort of their community
and their surroundings.
Is that sort of the idea of what you're saying
when you talk about information overload,
which may not be particularly useful?
Yeah, that's that's definitely part of it.
I mean, what we know about people is that
if you give them an unlimited amount of information,
they'll go out and cherry pick the information
that reinforces their existing biases.
Whether those biases are based on fact or
fantasy or fiction or whatever.
And so what happened to our hope when we tell
him we started out with the Net, with the
Web, was that we'd have such a broad array
of information that people would go out and
sample different opinions, different points
of view.
As you say, become better able to hear other
points, other people and influence them or
be influenced by them.
But what we found is that that rarely happens,
unfortunately.
What what what does happen is we all go out
in our little bubbles in it and gather the
information that supports our existing biases,
which ends up making those biases even stronger
than we find a lot of people that share those
biases.
And that has a lot to do with the polarization
we see today politically and socially, and
an inability to talk beyond the group of people
that that shares our point of view to use
this sort of economic term there.
There's arguably also a diminishing marginal
utility to information for decision making
purposes in the sense of, you know, if you're
buying a car as an example, that first information
that you obtain about, you know, you probably
have a budget.
Right.
So the price of cars is very important.
Do you need a two or.
Board or car or a sedan or an SUV.
Over time, the additional information seems
to be less and less useful to actually getting
to a decision.
Right when you get to.
What are the spark plugs?
What's the life of the of the LCD bulbs or
whatever?
And maybe that's also an idea to consider
here.
Yeah.
I think I think we're definitely onto something.
And I hadn't really considered that.
But, you know, and what happens, I think then
is one of two things.
Either you become so obsessed by the details
yet that you kind of you.
You spend all your time gathering more and
more.
Less and less valuable information, and it
prevents you from actually acting because
you suffer information paralysis.
And then the other thing is the degree, the
deeper you dig.
If we're talking about political speech, the
more reasons you find to to put other people
at a distance, the more points of difference
you start to uncover, even if they're trivial
points.
They loom large as you gather.
They'll keep gathering more and more information
without without necessarily.
As I said, fitting that information and understanding
that information as a part of a bigger, broader
context.
Yeah, that's something I've thought of in
thinking about, for example, like the political
divisions within the left.
Where?
Sure.
You have some on the left who are almost moderate
Republicans.
As an example.
And you have some on the left who are truly
socialists.
But really, there's probably, you know, pick
a number 85, 90.
I don't know what it would be, but there's
a lot of overlap about sort of what the majority
of those who consider themselves on the mainstream
American political left would want.
And yet, when you look at the discourse on
places like Twitter and others, it seems overwhelmingly
focused on the relatively small differences.
Yeah.
You know, in some ways that's nothing new.
People people have been, you know, subdividing
themselves, even with it, even when they share
a broad understand for a long time.
But I do think the Internet accelerates or
exaggerates that already common occurrence.
It provides not only all sorts of ways to
find new points of distinction, but to to
find ever narrower groups that share your
precise interests and your in your precise
views.
And as soon as you have that group formation,
then even other groups who share a lot of
your views seem like outsiders seem like the
enemy.
And I do think that's part of the fragmentation
we see even within within groups, groups of
people who you would think would focus on
their points of agreement to go back where
we started about the effects of the Internet
on our brains and deep thinking, et cetera.
When I've interviewed I interviewed Cal Newport
previously and read some of his books, and
he, at least to some degree, believes that
these are issues of sort of training and thinking
of the brain like a muscle, and that if you
condition the brain to you know, you really
you close a room and you just read 30 straight
minutes that you're building up a muscle essentially,
and that this helps to push back against the
instincts that may be pushed on us by sort
of the status quo of Western technology and
the Internet.
Is your take that the solution is a systemic
one, that it's at the individual level, the
absent one, it has to be the other or what?
What's your thought on that?
I certainly think it's I certainly think at
this point we've created a set of social norms
and social expectations that that essentially
tell us we should always be online, always
monitoring new information, always sending
out or receiving messages.
You get that from employers.
You get that from schools.
You get that certainly from your friends,
your relations.
So I think it's a systemic issue at this point.
And that doesn't that doesn't mean there's
not an individual component.
And I think Cowen, Cal Newport's analogy to
building, you know, building muscle is is
the right one.
What we know about neuroplasticity plasticity
these days, the brain's malleability, is that
you really do have to exercise ways of thinking
if you want to retain them.
Otherwise, they're going to weaken over time
and and ultimately disappear.
And I think as individuals, for a long time
now, we've been training ourselves to gather
information very, very quickly, to pull in
bits of data in lots of overlapping forms.
We're getting good at that.
But we have starved ourselves in effect or
not exercised the ability to pay attention,
which is hard for us to do, as I as I said.
So I think I think if we want to change.
You certainly have to pay attention to individual
habits.
But we also have to recognize that society
is sending these very powerful messages that
tell all of us, stay online, gather as much
information as you can, and don't turn off
the flow of information.
And in practice, the more attentive or contemplative
ways of thinking that are possible for your
mind, but don't come naturally to us.
We've been speaking with Nicholas Carr and
we're going to go to a break on the podcast,
TV and radio show.
You can find out our full conversation, which
will continue on the YouTube channel,